- That slide slide slide.
♪ I wish that I could find
a girl just like my mama ♪
(muffled speaking)
- There's Drake, oh my god.
It's Drake, oh it's Drake!
(hiphop music)
- It's surreal to be given
the opportunity to do it again
after such a long period of time.
The minute I got my hair cut into
the shade and trim, I was good to go.
You can look at culture
in the UK right now,
you look at music and
we're exploring a lot.
We're giving a lot of our
product to the rest of the world.
So I just felt like it was
perfect timing actually
the six year gap that came by accident,
actually made it perfect.
I think the world right
now is ready for the show.
(heavy bass music)
(laughter)
- I became attached to the
characters and I brought it up
to my manager, my partner in crime, I said
"Yo, we should try and bring this back."
- He always says to me when I talk to him
that he's a fan of show
first and foremost,
he's passionate about the
show because he likes it
and you couldn't get a better ambassador.
- Who's this, Michael Ward?
Michael ward?
- It's actually happening
man, I can't believe it.
It still doesn't feel real to me.
I obviously started as
a fan so I just want
everyone to see what I've seen
because what I've watched,
I've obviously watched it as a fan
and then I know we've
created something special
and I can't wait for everyone to see it.
I met Ashley back in '14,'15 begging him
for a role in Top Boy.
- You need to read it aloud.
- Wow the man's just taking
it in, but please read it.
- Hello Ashley just thought
it was worth a try to DM you
to see if you have any productions, please
could you get me a role, I
wanna be as big as you one day.
(applause)
- Hold on there's more,
there's more, there's more.
- How do I go about getting
a casting for Top Boy?
Please reply.
- Crying emoji, Crying emoji.
- It's mad.
(upbeat music)
- To think this was like
all in the works a year ago
and now we're on a premier,
at the premier it's crazy.
We've come to Netflix now
we've still kept that rawness,
we've still kept that edge,
and that as well was so
beautiful on screen and so cinematic
and I think everyone's going to love it.
I've been a fan of the show for so long
and to now know that I'm going
to be a part of the season
was crazy, I called my mom straight away
and was like, "guess what?"
- Twelve years ago, literally
around the corner from here,
I saw a kid on the street, dealing drugs
and that was the inspiration for Top Boy.
So to go from there to
here, has been a journey.
- The top, its worth losing
your people, your family.
- The slogan for this journey
that we're going on is
It's crowded at the top, to
be undisputed to where your
peers respect and fear
you at the same time
that to me is Top Boy.
- Whatever mindset to get to the top
you have to fight for what you want.